his clock ran out and kind of there's
there's no good move okay oh he made a
move with one second
so he took back a pawn so now it's level
material again
but uh magnus is getting one step closer
to his goal of just swapping off all the
pieces and being left with that pawn the
knights have disappeared
with that black's attacking hopes
disappear he makes a move with three
seconds this time he gives a check
and um the problem was you had to either
swap queens there or get checkmated as
black
now white's king needs to find safety it
does lots of safe squares
and the only the only check for black is
to take the queens off the board and as
soon as queens disappear
remember long term white is winning
because of that pawn okay also because
of how activist rooks are
but this is uh glorious for magnus
carlsen nice win
and it seems to be over yeah team rajiv
has resigned magnus carlsen winning his
first game in the quarter final he is
now up
by one point not giving us a smile here
magnus but he must be excited
yeah definitely i mean it just seemed
like a walk over